on a pris les deux plus gros succès de
ces dernières années on a pris
intouchable et validé on a mixé les deux
et on a fait un valide
ça donne ça nous en direct à l'antenne
qui diffuse ajouté écoute la chambre
basse ont offert un freestyle alors là
c'est un beau tir on dégaine sur un
planète rap d'anthologie franchement
qu'est-ce que tu décides moi je suis
chaud pour qu'ils montent un cela dépend
ce qu'on pense mais rhodia
elle va c'est parti allez je vois qu'on
entend il me semble que ses visées gars
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on va essayer de bien l'accueillir et le
courage de mon rang 4 ans le case on va
tous mourir ton micro question foot on
bat d'ailleurs un temps bastou pense pas
toshiba lance une instru pense que tu
veux je suis chaud à laisser partir
maintenant dans le studio
[Musique]
noah était trop beau j'ai envie de
dialoguer à fomenter un gangsta
il faut qu'il y ait du plaisir tu parles
avec fred musa
mais moi je m'appelle samir je veux que
tu restes là tu vas tu m'as vu tu as 20
janvier ça tombe bien moi non plus c'est
pas si tu tiens la main c'était mon bien
sûr de 2 et que des bus publics promis
meilleur des petits tête de cul pour le
moment cette amitié ne dit pas non si un
petit peu plus nous te situes en paix
pour me manger à midi
jean saint françois
je suis contente d'avoir en compte et
parce qu'en brett hull
tu le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
t'as fait ça mais un froid tu as fait un
freestyle propres et ou franchement
bravo monde franchement merci beaucoup
fraîcheur ça me touche ça dure on a
mangé une pièce vitrée et de la passion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement on va faire un super rapide
[Musique]
o o
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a fait 95 jours de tournage
exceptionnel merci beaucoup on peut
applaudir très très fort les coups de
valider ce qui plaît merci à tous
c'était vraiment plaisir je vous dis un
maximum de bruit s'il vous plaît